>> When I ask him how he would like to be
introduced this afternoon, he also told me
that he is one of the world's top boomerang
specialists.
Now, what that has to do with his predicting
the future -- at least he is good at predicting
what comes back at you if you throw it.
We'll see how that is useful during his speech.
He's a great individual.
He started out as a peace corps volunteer
and has that kind of dedication that we know
from a lot of colleagues who have done that
as well.
So with that, I just introduce -- Jerry will
have a talk and at the end, I hope you'll
leave enough time for some questions as well.
Jerome Glenn: Thank you, Frank.
It's a great pleasure to be here as it is
for anybody on the planet to be at Google.
It's one of the greatest enterprises in history.
Pleasure to be here.
What I'd like to do is, if anybody has a question,
ask it at the time that you want to, you know?
You don't have to wait till the very end.
The Millenium Project was a very far-out idea
in the late or mid-1980's.
Thought was that the year 2000 would occur
and journalists would stick microphone down
the throats of various futurists around the
world and say, "Okay, tell me everything about
the next thousand years." or something silly
like that.
And we were worried that, if we had too much
to drink the night before, we might not say
anything useful, and we may waste an opportunity
in the year 2000.
So the thought was, we should create some
system -- some idea -- that was important
for one generation, or one millennium gift
to the next.
And the thought was to create a global participatory
think tank for humanity.
There are tons of think tanks for countries.
There's think tanks for ideologies.
There's think tanks for water.
There's think tanks for all kinds of stuff,
but there was no think tank for we human beings
as a whole.
Now, you could say, "Well, doesn't the World
Bank do that?" Yes, but they do it for economics.
Or don't say the World -- what about the CIA?
Well, the CIA does it for United States.
But where do you go to get a picture of the
whole game?
And this was during the Cold War, so it was
not exactly an easy task.
Fortunately, the Cold War ended when we started.
We started officially in 1996, after a three-year
feasibility study.
I don't know if there's ever been a three-year
feasibility study for anything other than
the Millennium Project.
And then that was -- before that was a one-year
feasibility study to answer the question that
the United Nations University asked us to
answer, which was, "Somebody must be trying
to do this already."
I mean, it's an obvious idea to have a bunch
of futurists around the world collaborating
to figure out the whole game.
That's an obvious idea, it must be done by
somebody.
And so far, we couldn't find anybody, so we
started it.
So how do you create a think tank on behalf
of humanity?
We decided that it had to be pulled together
by U.N. systems -- you know, U.N.
University, UNESCO, U.N.D.P.
But also it involved with governments.
The first funding actually came from the U.S.
Environmental Protection Agency for the feasibility
study.
NGOs -- corporations -- and woe, how did we
do that?
We jumped too quickly. Be right back here.
Okay.
Where's my little thing? There we go. All
right –
So the Millennium Project was put together
by U.N. organizations, governments, NGOs,
corporations, and universities.
The idea was that, if we're going to do this
on behalf of humanity, it ought to cut across
all these institution categories.
It can't be just an academic exercise.
It can't be just a political thing.
It can't be just an NGO thing.
It had to be cutting across the systems.
So we operate as what we call a 'trans-institution'.
Now, there's no such thing legally as a trans-institution.
We hope that we'll get some country to amend
their corporate law -- you've got nonprofit
law, profit law, and we want to have trans-institution
law.
By a 'trans-institutional law' and registered
as a trans-institution, what we mean is that
all the people doing the work, or whatever
it is -- whether it's for AIDS or ours happen
to be for the future, improving education,
whatever it happens to be -- that the people
doing the work ought to come from each of
these institutional categories, but not a
majority of any one.
The money should come from all these institutional
categories, but not a majority of any one.
The governing body of the organization should
come from all these categories, but not a
majority of any one.
And you should prove value at the end of the
year in annual report or some activity to
show that you've produced value for all these
institutional categories.
Now, the trans-institution is extremely efficient
entity.
I think it will be a new kind of institution
in the future.
We've got all kinds of innovations in software,
in medicine, aerodynamics, but we don't have
much innovation in institutional design.
And I think this is one of them.
Because when you want to act, you can act
through any one of these categories.
When you want to do some of your water work,
you can act through UNESCO, or the U.N. system,
for example.
If you want to do some collective intelligence
work -- which we'll talk about -- maybe you
can act through Google.
But then you're also acted on by all these
categories.
So when the Millennium Project does work,
it wants to be influenced by all these institutional
categories and it wants to act through all
those institutional categories.
Key element here is they should be self-organizing.
If I assign somebody to do it, then I got
to manage them, but these should be people
who -- One, they should be attracted to the
activity.
So you can't have every corporation involved.
You can't have every government involved.
It's too complex.
But those that want to play, let them self-select
so that you have enthusiasm and you get better
synergies this way.
Now, we have mini trans-institutions -- not
perfect -- but mini ones around the world
that are called 'nodes.' And when I use the
word 'node,' I mean an intersection of two
or more networks.
So there's networks of government players.
There's networks of corporate players.
There's networks of university players.
Where they intersect, we call a node.
And we have a node here in Silicon Valley.
Jack Park is a member here in the audience.
And some others in the area are working on
venture capital, software, and the things
of Silicon Valley.
So the idea is, this becomes a brain-picking
system for the Millennium Project.
How do you pick the brains of the world?
Well, this is our answer to that.
It's also our answer to -- you hear people
talk about "Global local" all the time.
This is our management answer to how you do
global/local.
So that we can send a question out to these
nodes -- or these 33 nodes around the world
-- and say, "Who knows the most about water?"
for example.
Each of these nodes -- the node is composed
of these different categories, so they can
say, "Okay, who knows the most in universities?
Who knows the most in corporations?
Who knows the most in NGOs?
Who knows the most in the U.N. representatives
here?
Who knows the most?" And then, since they're
doing it in their own cultures, they're talking
to them in Farsi or Hebrew or whatever language
it happens to be.
And they're doing the recruitment.
So I'm not telling who should be in; they're
telling us who should be in.
All right. So these nodes then is the factor
for a participatory process.
They also can be headquarters for something.
For example, the tech awards here in Silicon
Valley was a spin-off of the Millennium Project.
And when the tech awards got going for innovations
in the five categories, we said -- some of
our players in the node here in Silicon Valley
said, "Well, we ought to do something with
all these finalists in these tech awards."
So then, they help get business planning.
So it was just to get an award and some publicity
and applause, they now get venture capital,
business management training, innovations
from a lot of hot shots here in Silicon Valley.
But that's a contribution to the whole world.
Each of these nodes is like a headquarters
for something else.
In Mexico City, they run a similar contest
for how to address the 15 global millennium
challenges -- which I'll talk about in a second
-- with high school students around the world.
In Korea -- and I'll talk a little bit more
about that -- they're wanting to put together
a global climate change situation room.
And hopefully we'll maybe collaborate with
someone here in Google, or at least we'll
use your products in how to create a collective
intelligence for a global climate change situation
room.
And if we do that correctly, that'll be something
that all the other nodes can share and maybe
the U.N. systems as well.
So this is sort of the management structure
of the Millennium Project.
We have two categories of things that the
project produces.
One is methods.
This is Future Research Methodology version
3.0.
It has 39 chapters.
More than half of the chapters have been written
by the author of the method -- or the inventor
of the method -- or someone who's contributed
significantly to that methods evolution.
It's about 1,300 pages.
It's the largest collection of methods to
explore the future international peer review
that's ever been assembled anywhere and there's
not even a close second.
So for those here in Google looking at future
trends and future ideas and what's next and
all that sort of stuff, here's some methods
you may want to look through to see if there's
something in there that you haven't used that
you might be able to use.
The other is the state of the future.
That's the content part.
And that looks like a report or a book.
It's also a management technique for us, because
I had worked for right wing, left wing, up
wing, down wing think tanks and I was tired
of the nonsense that if one think tank says
it, then another think tank says, "Well, they've
got to be wrong."
We all know that every think tank's got some
sort of value.
So we ought to create something across the
board, which is part of the evolution of the
Millennium Project.
But one of the things that weren't being done
was, think tanks would do a report, and then
they would do another study, another report
-- another study, another report.
Or some would get together some big thing
like the Club of Rome or the inter-futures
or some big thing, big applause, and there's
no cumulative wisdom going on.
There's no system to improve the improvement
of the improvement system.
There's no systematic approach to that.
So we figured we would have to do a "State
of the Future" report each year.
And then, we would have to make sure that
that report is better than last year.
So what we write about water this year has
to be more important than what I wrote about
last year.
So there's 13 of these things have been done
so far.
So anybody can see, Is there an evolution
of knowledge and better precision and so forth,
or not?
So this is our own sort of self-evaluation
tool.
It comes in two parts.
One is about a hundred pages, very short summaries
of various things for people to look at that
are too busy to do the academic research.
And then, the CD ROM that's got 6,700 pages.
So those who want the short version, you go
to print.
And those who want the details behind the
research -- What did the invitation letter
look like?
What did the questionnaire look like?
What was the demographics?
all the detail behind it -- is in the CD ROM.
So we began by saying, "What's happening in
the world that is going to become a very big
thing in, say, 25 years that is either not
known generally or is misunderstood?
What's going on? And what's that going to
look like in ten years?
And what's that going to look like in 25 years?
And give us a reference."
So it wasn't just an opinion survey.
People had to do some work to bring in ideas.
And we collected something like 280 developments.
And went through a long, tortuous process
of interviewing policymakers and feedback
systems.
And I won't bore you with that.
We ended up with 15 issues.
And our planning committee said, "That's nice.
You acted like engineers.
You've identified all these issues or problems.
What about all the opportunities?
What about the good stuff?"
So the next year, we did the same sort of
process of having people ask these questions
all around the world and doing the interviews.
We ended up with almost the same number -- 280-some-odd
developments of good things that were important
-- either misunderstood or not known -- that
could evolve in the future.
Then the third year, we put the two together
into the challenges.
And then one of the people -- one of the planning
committee members from Finland said, "Look,
stop changing please. We like your framework.
We use it in our Committee for the Future
in Parliament to do our evaluation.
If you keep changing it, it's difficult for
us."
So we haven't changed.
We kept the 15 challenges since then up to
the present tense.
We may still change them, but so far, we think
it's the best framework to understand what's
happening in the world.
First challenge -- and I won't go into detail
in all of these things.
There's just too much information, but you
can get it in the State of the Future.
the first -- and by the way, when I say 'first,'
it is not the most important.
All 15 of these challenges are important,
just like your brain is important and your
heart is important and one is not more important
than the other.
But when you study biology, you know, you
get to list down the systems.
So we're listing down these systems.
This is a system. They're interdependent.
If you improve one, you help the others. If
you hurt one, you hurt the others.
This is the system. This is the agenda for
humanity, but it's a system.
So don't get lost in the idea that your preferred
challenge is number six on the list.
They're all a hundred percent important.
So how can sustainable development be achieved
by all, while addressing global climate change?
As you know that we probably consume more
material on the Earth since World War II than
all the years in the past.
You all know all the issues of sustainability
-- I don't need to tell you.
We cannot continue as we are.
One of the issues, though, that we'd like
more people to take seriously is this 'parts
per million' people talk about in carbon.
It has been discussed, Should we have 550
parts per million carbon in the atmosphere,
or should it be 450?
It is now about 391 parts per million, and
we already have major ice areas of the Andes
and the Himalayas and so forth around the
world going down.
And that means that rivers change -- dry up.
It means that farming changes.
It means, if we got mass migration coming
up, we got serious stuff.
So 390 parts per million is not sustainable
now.
To say that we have 450, to me, is a sham.
When people say it's politically -- we can't
do a better job than that politically, I'm
going, "Well, you know, nature doesn't care
about the politics with all due respect."
So for those of you involved in the Climate
Change Conference, I hope you hold to the
350 mark rather than the 450 mark.
How could we have enough water for everybody
without conflict?
As some of you may know -- Frank does, I'm
sure -- over 40 percent of humanity gets its
water today from sources, watersheds, that
are controlled by two or more countries.
And that's not necessarily so bad by itself,
but you take the next fact, and it's a real
problem.
The water tables -- the water layer underneath
the ground -- on all continents are going
down and have been going down for some years.
This is a very serious prescription for conflict
-- continuing conflict.
In China and India, what -- 40 percent of
humanity -- they're having very serious water
problems.
Our node chair in China was involved in those
water scenarios ten years ago.
And they had good case/best case/worst case/middle
case scenarios.
And in China, the water scenarios in China
-- it showed that the situation in China
would get worse the next 15 to 17 years in
the best case scenario.
Meaning that another 20 years, you're as bad
off as you are now, but you got a lot more
people.
So holding political stability in China and
India -- it's going to be extremely difficult
just from the point of view of water -- let
alone energy problems, let alone Northwest
China with the Islamic situation, let alone
the rich/poor gaps going on in these countries.
We -- and since I'm here in Google -- we in
the United States are living to some degree
in a bubble of stability, of relative peace
and so forth.
If you look at the world in terms of what
makes instability -- list the various factors
and so forth -- and go around the world and
take a look at what's going on.
About half the world is potentially unstable.
Doesn't mean it will go, but about half is
potentially unstable, and water is one of
the major issues on this Earth.
We've got to create new forms of water.
There's all kinds of new breakthroughs coming
up.
We've got to look at all kinds of ways to
move from fresh water agriculture to salt
water.
If you take a look at agriculture, it turns
out that agriculture is the largest user of
water.
And the majority of that use of water is for
animals.
If you do a Google search on growing meat
without animals -- or having meat without
growing animals -- you'll find out there's
extraordinary amount of research going on
right now to replace the use of pigs, cows,
goats, growing them to do meat.
We've got another 2.5 billion people coming
up on the planet before 2050.
Because of the Googles of the world and various
Internet things, we've redistributed the means
of creating wealth, which means these people
would be probably wealthier than they were
in the last 50 years.
As wealth goes up, meat consumption goes up.
If meat consumption goes up, the water use
on the land goes up.
And because there's a limited amount of land,
that means the price of food will go up.
Little children need iron and protein -- as
a child growing up -- for their brain to work
properly.
Meat is one of the best ways to get iron and
protein together.
It's not the only way, but it's one of the
most efficient.
People say, "Well, why not go to vegetarian?"
Okay, that's fine.
But don't forget that the meat consumption
goes up in India when income goes up.
So if India cannot hold it as a culture, how
can the rest of the world do it?
So it seems we need to think about how we
can get protein without growing animals and
all the problems with that.
And it looks like that's going to happen.
There's been a lot of progress.
The first patent was filed, by the way, in
the Netherlands in -- I think it was 1999
-- six months after I gave a talk to a guy
who was from the Netherlands on the issue.
But moving from animals' production to make
meat to animaless production of meat, we'd
save a lot of land and a lot of water -- free
up fresh water.
Secondly, there's a lot of species that can
grow in salt water. A lot of plants.
Along beaches in the water, but on the beaches
as well.
We can irrigate along the coastlines of the
world and do salt water agriculture.
That would free up also more fresh water as
well.
Now, if you can grow these plants along coastlines
of the world -- like the Somalis, if they
ever stop shooting each other, but places
like Somalia with baking sun coming down like
crazy.
There's no vegetation in a lot of these coastlines.
It's desert areas.
But you can irrigate with salt water, so you
can get rid of -- not only some of the fresh
water problems with this, but one of the biggest
problems farmers have today is, "Is it going
to rain enough?" You don't have an issue of
drought.
Drought doesn't matter.
You can have a drought along Somalia forever
and salt water agriculture is going to have
the coastline green -- green for biofuels
-- because algae, as you know, is the greatest
producer of biofuels by far.
You can grow it like crazy in salt water and
stuff.
You can have food for humans, food for animals,
and you can have paper products.
And it's also a carbon sink, because your
green weed and not have it be for anything
else.
Anyway, these are just a couple ideas of how
to address the water situation.
How can population growth and resources be
brought into balance?
One quick little note on there that's not
being paid attention to is that most of your
population projections go up to 2050.
Do your Google search to 2100 and get what
the graph looks like.
It goes up to 2050 and it starts to come back
down. Why?
You have fewer -- the fertility rate goes
down, as fewer women later on having the babies,
okay?
Now, what that means is that you'll end up
with -- if those trends continue, which I
don't think they will, but we got to take
them seriously -- is that means that vast
majority by 2100 will be retired people.
The social contract to handle retirement is
going up in cost around the world.
How can you run a civilization when the majority
of people are old and retired?
I don't think that can work.
So either we got to get the fertility rate
going, or we go like Japan and have a bunch
of robots, or longevity kicks in.
And longevity research is progressing quite
well.
Some of you are probably aware of it, but
one simple, simple, simple idea is the telomeres.
You know, the ends of the DNA -- telomeres.
If we learn how to manage that relationship
-- that's a mechanical definition of aging
is, You can lose that material, you're rolling
out older stuff.
That's one approach.
We're also finding out about how to re-stimulate
stem cells, put them back into the body in
the brain.
Maybe we can make an artificial biology, little
microbes that can clean out the plaque.
There's a lot of ways that are in research
now.
But the long-term population problem is actually
the aging problem.
The short-term -- the next 50 years -- obviously
it's the overcrowding, which then goes back
to the efficiencies, addressing these challenges
very fast.
How can genuine democracy emerge from authoritarian
regimes?
I'd like you to know that democracy has been
-- as you can probably guess -- a good, growing,
healthy trend.
But not for the last several years.
Press freedoms have actually gone down in
the last seven years.
Political freedoms have gone down -- a little
bit, not a whole lot, a little bit -- in the
last two or three years.
So it is not a done deal that democracy wins.
Also, it's not a gone deal that voting democracies
is the only form of democracy.
I mean, it seems to me we can rethink some
new forms.
Maybe some of the stuff being developed here
in Google of self-organization is a new form
of governance.
How can policymaking be made more sensitive
to long-term global perspectives?
How can global convergence of information
and communication technologies work for everyone?
I suppose there's a few answers in this organization.
How can ethical market economies be encouraged
to help reduce the gap between the rich and
the poor?
One thing that might be an interesting project
-- it just ran across my mind right now for
Google to volunteer on -- imagine you create
a website of some sort and that you have -- in
a lot of poor countries, they have very well-educated
people who go and work for UNESCO or work
for the World Bank or work for Google or something
like that.
And they're not necessarily going back.
And they feel guilty and they give money back.
There's a major activity, giving money back
to the Third World.
Wouldn't it be nice if they can give some
of the brain power back too?
Why not do a simple, matching program between
the development needs of the person's host/original
country and those hot shots in Europe, United
States, Japan, and so forth to create like
telenations?
A thought to think about.
There you can use the power of the market
in developing relations as well as -- All
right, for example, let's say that you are
very good analyst on business plans.
The average person in say, Malawi, doesn't
know how to do a business plan, okay?
Well, maybe the development and DMAC organization
in Malawi has a little computer connection
we set up some years ago, and they put in
their, "Here are some business plans."
And that goes back to a Malawian let's say
working for the World Bank.
For him, it's no big deal going through the
business plans and finding the mistakes, and
making some suggestions.
So the small business people in Malawi are
getting hot shot, first class, business management
consulting.
For him, it's a lark. It's sort of fun.
Maybe an hour a week, he can do it.
For these people, it's livelihoods. It's growth
of the country.
Anyway, just think of it -- matching up the
development needs of the world through the
brain power of the world, and especially those
that have left those countries to start with.
How can the spread of new and reemerging diseases
and immune microorganisms be reduced?
As you may know, for the last 40 years, about
one new disease we didn't have before has
come up.
The normal model of sequencing the gene, creating
a vaccine, producing the vaccine, getting
it out -- that takes time.
Even though we're down to sequencing in a
couple of weeks, very fast, it is not maybe
the answer long-term.
Because if it's the case that humans are compressing
themselves into urban environments more and
more and more, and we're compressing ourselves
into new forms of pollution that we didn't
have before, if we're jet-planing around the
world more than before, it is reasonable to
assume that the mutation and change in communicability
of serious, infectious diseases will be worse
in the future than in the past.
And if we're going with the same old strategy,
we may not win.
So another approach is -- it's coming indirectly
out of age research -- is to understand the
immune system better.
And then, understand it enough so that we
can bring up the immune system to total strength,
that no matter what the agent coming in, it
holds it off long enough for the agent to
die.
So it's a temporary hold.
So imagine if Ebola or hemorrhagic fever goes
airborne.
That's a pretty nasty image of the future.
But if you had material that could bring up
the immune system very fast, you had it like
fire extinguishers -- you know, you had fire
extinguishers in different place.
You don't know where the fire is going to
be, but fire comes up, you contain it and
that's it.
Well, imagine doing that as a model for communicable
diseases -- having these things around, so
if something comes up in a certain place,
you can immunize that area.
You can hold the disease in that area.
But we're going to have to come up with new
models of treating communicable diseases,
because I don't think our current direction
is sustainable.
How can the capacity to decide be improved
as the nature of work and institutions change?
We all know that the political process is
pretty well clogged and it's awfully complex
and it doesn't seem to be getting unclogged.
So we need all kinds of innovations in this
area.
How can shared values and new security strategies
reduce the ethnic conflicts, terrorism, and
use of weapons of mass destruction?
I will tell you first of all from our experience
in doing the Millennium Project and its research
for the last 13 years have convinced me that
almost every nasty problem you could throw
out, there are some solutions.
It's a question of getting the right information,
the right people, right time -- all that sort
of stuff -- and the will to do it.
Most of these things I've talked about have
answers to them.
You may argue about which answer, but there's
answers.
Here's one that's not an easy one.
You take out the trends of artificial biology,
computer-aided design, and 3-D biological
printing, and the lower costs of all these
capacities, you end up with the possibility
of an individual acting alone, creating a
bioweapon and deploying it to wipe out an
awful lot of the world.
That's not here today, but it is possible
tomorrow.
How do you prevent that?
Most of the systems of deterrents are thinking
in terms of countries, ethnic groups, and
things like that.
But what about the mentally ill person who
says, "Ah, the Bible says people were so wicked,
God wipes them out with a flood, and we start
over again."
Why couldn't someone come up with that same
conclusion?
Because it wouldn't need a flood; you got
other means to do it.
This is a serious, long-term problem to address.
And very quickly, the direction to prevent
it -- not good answers -- but the direction
is, very low-cost, nano, multisensor networks
of nanotechnology networks -- biologicals,
radiologicals, pressure, temperature etc.
so that you can start to monitor everybody
as much as possible.
Every molecule change in public space wandering
direction.
But that's not good enough by itself, because
-- as you all know here -- if you could understand
something, you can digitalize it.
If you can digitalize it, you could hack it
or change it.
So that's good, but not good enough.
The other is, we want to reduce the population
of crazy people who might do this.
I assume all of you are not interested in
wiping out civilization, so I'm not worried
about you.
You think about what percentage of the world
is psychotic enough that they would want to
wipe out the world?
It's a small percent.
But a small percent of say in 2050, nine billion
people, is quite a few people.
And by 2050, that capacity I just described
certainly will be around at that time.
So we want to reduce that number -- so we
can take from cognitive science, take from
learning theory, and integrate what we know
about how a healthy human gets evolved and
take that deadly seriously -- not just simply
as an education exercise, but deadly seriously
as important for all of us idealistically,
but it's important.
Idealistically to take care of everybody's
health growing up, because it only takes one
person in this scenario, right?
So you want to reduce the numbers of people,
you want to increase the sensitivity of the
senses.
Those are the directions, but they're not
good answers yet.
How can changing status of women improve the
human condition?
I don't know if you know it, but the largest
war on the planet today is men killing and
hurting women.
In the United Nations, we define war as 1,000
or more deaths a year.
By that definition, it's the largest war.
It's bigger than the war on terrorism.
It's bigger than Afghanistan.
But it's not being taken seriously.
And this is an issue that's for us as a human
family to think through -- do we want to call
it a war?
I don't know if it helps or hurts, actually.
But I knew that we are not -- we males especially
-- but we as a species are not taking seriously
the violence toward women.
One of the fun suggestions I gave in a teleconference
the other day in Italy was the idea of having
martial arts as a part of the normal physical
education curriculum in public schools.
And what that would mean by the time you're
12 years -- or 12th grade -- if you've gone
through 12 years of martial art training,
you're probably a black belt or two or three
black belts, and very few men will attack
a three-belt martial art master.
Now, that's not the answer to the thing, but
it maybe can help deter -- just like during
the Cold War we deterred folks from having
the war.
How can trans-national organized crime networks
be stopped from becoming more powerful and
sophisticated global enterprises?
If you take all the military budgets of the
world, you add them up, it's about 1.3, 1.5
trillion with a T -- trillion dollars.
Organized crime is about twice that worldwide.
I want that to sink in.
Think of the infrastructure of the militaries
of the world.
Think of the cash. Think of the personnel.
Think of the influence. Think of its activities.
Then double that and have it not on the radar
map of most futurists in the world.
It's extremely important.
According to the World Bank, about one trillion
dollars are paid out in bribes.
Let's say you knock out all the drug issues,
you knock out illegal smuggling of weapons
and prostitution and various other sort of
activities, what happens?
That means that that money for that activity
goes into new areas.
What new areas might organized crime go into?
They might be able to buy and sell government
decisions, like they buy and sell heroin.
This would make democracy an illusion.
We need a global, integrated strategy to address
global organized crime.
We don't have that.
We barely have it in countries, because we
divide up the policy in different areas.
You know, this guy's working on numbers, this
person is working on illegal drug traffic,
this person's working on this.
But what is the integrated global strategy?
Another task -- another challenge for us.
How can the global energy demands be safely
and efficiently met?
How can scientific and technological breakthroughs
be accelerated to improve the human condition?
And how can ethical considerations become
more routinely incorporated into global decisions?
This is the agenda put together by over 13,
14, 15 years of various futurists and policy
people around the world.
This is what we got to get done.
Now, one of the first challenge in dealing
with climate change.
I'm very pleased to say the Millennium Project
has been asked to help create the global climate
change situation room in South Korea.
We did a little study a couple of years ago
on how you would create a collective intelligence
to address energy.
And so, we may be using that model and apply
that to the situation room being created in
South Korea.
And we would invite any of the employees in
Google to play with us.
Because as you all know, you may design a
system, but when you get into it, you try
to improve it.
So we hope by the time we actually put the
situation room together, it'll be a real collective
intelligence that all in the world can draw
on.
It will be a physical situation room, but
the collective intelligence behind it should
be available to everybody.
And so, we have more and more people involved
in this, because this is a human family issue.
But the nice thing about the situation room
-- ______ think from just collective intelligence
-- is that you also are taking a look at
what governments say they're doing, what the
policies are, what the gaps are, what the
limitations are, what the status is.
So that you're actually getting on phones
and getting arm twisters to move it.
So the purpose of the situation was to manage
something.
We don't have -- you can do a Google search
on this -- we don't have, to my knowledge,
a situation room.
And if you find it, I want to know it -- a
situation room to manage the global climate
change management issues.
We've got the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change, but that's science, research, collaboration,
with a political veneer laid on top of it.
But where do you go to see the whole situation?
I know, you've got to go to Google to see
the whole situation.
But let's -- maybe we can work together on
this one.
All right. What do I mean by 'collective intelligence'?
I mean an emergent property first of all.
It's not a thing itself.
It's not all of us sitting here making decision.
I don't mean that as collective intelligence.
I mean it's an emergent property.
It's something that isn't there when you start
to do it.
It emerges from the synergies among data knowledge
information, hardware/software experts, that
continually learns from feedback to produce
nearly adjusted time knowledge for better
decisions than those actions -- than those
elements acting alone.
That's what I mean when I say, 'collective
intelligence' -- emergent properties.
So imagine creating a collective intelligence
for climate change.
It's an emergent property and keeps growing
and improving through time.
And then you're cooking it up to decision
makers for actions, like a situation room
should do.
One of the -- this is an abstract version
of maybe an interface.
We may or may not do it this way, but this
is one of the ideas -- is that we find continually
that people get lost in detail and forget
the big picture.
And the big picture people sometimes don't
know enough detail to make the right decisions.
So this is the quandary.
So one of the things, We want to have information
displayed so they can always see where the
piece fits into the whole all the time.
This is one of the ideas.
These may be three columns or four columns,
maybe different ways of doing the searches,
but this is one.
The idea here is, How do you create a user
interface so as people do their searches -- as
they do their work -- they're seeing how the
part relates to the whole?
Another aspect of this is that -- let's say
for example, here's an information unit, or
a piece of information about photovoltaic
efficiency.
What we would like is that that piece of information
is linked to the column on the right-hand
side.
First would be the overview.
Let me jump ahead and come back in a second.
By overview, there's an old antique software
called CM1.
Some of you may remember it.
There's a way if you have a question like,
"How do you make photovoltaics more efficient?
What are the three or four different categories
of research on that?
What are the pro and cons from each of this?
And what are the references behind it?
Why?" Because people need to see the whole
picture, but they can't be overloaded by all
the detail.
So this would be one kind of approach to having
an overview of an issue.
So you went back up here.
So a piece of information would be linked
to its overview.
Second, what are the problems and opportunities?
Where do they come from?
Well, we'd have groups of networks that the
Millennium Project would organize around the
world.
They would be doing discussion in various
collaborative systems, and we would be able
to identify the problems and opportunities
through that.
We'd also be doing research, What's the data
in forecast about that piece of information?
Are there computer simulations that you can
run?
What are the expert ratings?
We -- the Millennium Project has developed
a software called Realtime Delphites, a polling
system that updates from realtime so that
we could constantly update among experts rating
on a new piece of information as it comes
in and rank-order them, by the way, in the
display system.
What are the unresolved issues?
As they rate these -- if you have a bipolar
distribution, that's clearly an unresolved
issue, so it would be empirical on that.
And we'd have open, non-peer-reviewed information
as well.
More open -- more contemporary view here is
the issues-based information system that we
will probably be using.
But the idea is to keep track of how the conversation
goes in an organized, logical structure.
One of the problems with blogs is that people
repeat themselves -- it's one thing after
another, after another, after another, after
another; it's a pain in the neck -- whereas
this way, you would have the information being
edited if all goes well in these units -- each
is a wiki by itself.
It's going to a wiki point by itself.
So that the overview of an issue is continually
updated.
So it's not a database unit that sits there
dead in the water.
It's dynamic itself.
Another is for the decision maker players.
We want to be able to create some dashboards
like this, for example.
So that they can know the status of a decision.
Because there's two kinds of clients for this
situation room.
One, are the people who want to understand
to know.
The other is people who make decisions.
Those are two different kinds of requirements.
This is more for the paid decision makers.
Like, what is a total picture on a particular
issue?
This happens to be solar power satellites.
What's the total picture I got to know in
one shot?
But then these elements are dynamic.
They can keep changing.
My colleague in front of me -- Jack Park -- you
probably talk about this in the question/answer
period we can go into this.
But the idea is that we want to federate all
the capabilities and have people tagging information
so that they get linked up in ways that we
didn't know were even possible.
This is part of his idea of an emergent property.
So how could you all participate?
One. We'd like to talk to whomever's interested
in how we develop this situation room in Korea.
Two. If all goes well, I hope I can get Frank
to continue to be involved in the water projects
and how Google can be involved in those scenarios
and display information systems for those
scenarios in the U.N. or scenarios with UNESCO.
The second is, we hope to take the 15 global
challenges I just went through, create a collective
intelligence for each one, and link them up.
This would be a pretty good beginning of a
global brain.
We also are teaching online courses on these
issues around the world.
And I am sure that there are some new products
-- certain things coming up in Google that
we probably haven't used yet -- or know about
-- that could make those courses even better
online.
And of course, we'd be happy to have you have
a sponsor.
These are the people who were behind the Millennium
Project in the past.
As I mentioned before, we get income from
different categories -- corporations, governments,
foundations, and so forth.
And that's all I have to say.
Any questions? Yeah.
Q [inaudible]
Jerome Glenn: Good. Perfecto. Perfecto.
Now, understand. Just like in your working
world, you can be overruled by somebody later
on who's got a better idea.
But this is where I am so far on it.
Is I see like two semantic wikis in parallel.
This one is the experts; this one is non-experts.
But they're looking at each other.
So the people that are pulling up this stuff
in the non-expert area, they may be experts
-- we didn't know about them -- and then
they can switch over into here.
So there's a relationship.
It's like a farm team for this.
So if some stuff is far out over here -- no
problem -- it can be there.
It is documenting the non-peer review stuff.
But at the same time -- my first e-mail was
1973.
I've been involved in computer communication
stuff for a long time.
And one thing I can tell you is that quality
as a generalization is driven out of network
systems on these collaborative group systems,
because you have somebody comes in, "Wow,
this is great.
I can improve my future, my career.
I'm going to come in here and hang out with
these hot shots."
And they say now, "What do you mean by a search
engine?" And we go like, "Who let him in the
door?" And then, eventually, the hot shots
start to leave out.
So we want to figure out how to solve that
problem, because we really want to have top
brains in collaboration that haven't necessarily
been collaboration before for whatever reason.
But we wanted them to be able to work together
without having a lot of noise.
At the same time -- we all know -- good ideas
come out of left field, right field, up field,
down field, right?
So my answer so far -- until you or somebody
else comes up with a different approach -- is
to have two parallel systems, but have them
inform each other and federates so that there's
information can actually cut across.
But you don't ask the expert to read 50 e-mails
a day.
He'll leave.
>> [pause]
Q [inaudible]
Jerome Glenn: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, little
detail.
We've got about 1,400 pages on the 15 challenges
already.
So yes, we'll start with a lot of stuff that
we've done over a bunch of years and sort
of like chumming the waters to begin with.
Yeah. No. We would dump what we have in the
system.
And that would grow very rapidly I am sure.
Q [inaudible]
Jerome Glenn: Oh. Well, we've passed the recommendation
point.
We've already been contracted. We will do
it.
I just -- we haven't -- as a matter of fact,
right after this talk, some of the players
will be meeting near NASA Ames, and we're
going to be going through some of the implementation
steps.
So it's not that we're recommending -- we'll
be recommending to ourself how to do it.
The Korean organization has already said,
"We want you to do it."
They have seen our previous ideas.
They saw the genus model.
You saw the opening slide there that have
already got the political people done.
So to do it or not to do it, we're past that.
Now the question is, "How?"
Now, we've had a plan -- we have ideas, but
that doesn't mean that's what it's going to
be a year from now.
I mean, we bring together a bunch of hot shots,
they're going to out-think each other.
So we're going to be growing as we go along.
But we're starting with -- I guess maybe part
of your question is -- we have a initial planning
committee that we're working with.
And we will start cranking out the software,
putting the stuff in, having the meetings,
changing and so forth.
So we're right now at the beginning start
up of it.
That's one of the good things about the timing
today.
[pause] Okay? Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]